at this theater in Kiev a dress
rehearsal begins and two veteran
Ukrainian actors run through their
scenes
memorizing the dialogue has been easy
maintaining their focus has not
in one moment a rocket could land near
you and everything could come to an end
these factors aren't helping
but for all involved the production has
become about much more than simply
putting on a play some facts the fact
that we are still performing for our
audience is resistance itself because
we're not afraid we did not run away
as director of velodimir kudlinski gives
notes to the cast he recounts how the
theater on podil a well-known cultural
institution had closed down after
Russia's Invasion and only reopened in
June
we were surprised that the audiences of
stating cave started to buy tickets and
came to the performances hours later at
the same theater another play is being
staged but it's interrupted even before
it begins
so we've just gotten another reminder of
how things can change here minute to
minute people had come out to see a play
tonight the audience members were going
in to take their seats and then the air
raid sirens rang out again uh over Kiev
and so they were directed to come back
down here into the lobby of the theater
where they must sit until they're given
the all clear patrons are determined not
to let this ruin a much needed outing
this is important because it's a
distraction from the danger from the
constant anxiety when you are surrounded
by other people you feel like you're in
another life it's comforting
when the show finally begins it promises
to transport the audience
within minutes though another siren
for the actors and Their audience the
spell May temporarily be broken but the
spirit of defiance very much remains